Visit ListenLively.com
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: JOE BIDEN
ABSOLUTELY DOMINATED LAST
NIGHT’S PRIMARIES.
ALL THE RESULTS AREN’T IN BUT IT
LOOKS LIKE A CLEAN SWEEP.
FOUR OF THE SIX STATES IN
CONTENTION, OVERWHELM
BERNIE SANDERS BY MORE THAN 15
POINTS THE KEY STATE OF
MICHIGAN.
EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON NOW
ASSUMES AS A MATTER OF FAITH
THAT BIDEN WILL BE THE
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
THEY ARE THRILLED BY THIS.
JUST INCREDIBLY AND PROFOUNDLY
RELIEVED THAT BERNIE SANDERS HAS
BEEN SUBDUED.
DOLORES O’DONNELL DOESN’T LIVE
IN WASHINGTON BUT HE MIGHT AS
WELL.
O’DONNELL IS A WALKING OR
VESUVIUS OF CONVENTIONAL WISDOM.
WHEN LAWRENCE O’DONNELL SPEAKS
HE IS SPEAKING FOR THE ENTIRE
SELF-SATISFIED POLITICAL CLASS.
HERE’S HIS CONCLUSION ON
JOE BIDEN.
>> HIS OPENING LINE WAS "THIS IS
YOUR CAMPAIGN."
HE DID IT IN THE MOST GENEROUS
WAYS HE COULD.
HE HAD A VERY SOFT TONE OF
VOICE, AS IF YOU’RE IN THE
LIVING ROOM WITH HIM.
HE REALLY WAS TRYING TO CREATE I
THINK COMFORT, STABILITY, TALKED
ABOUT PRESIDENTIAL LEADERSHIP.
HE SAID IF YOU GIVE ME THE HONOR
OF BECOMING YOUR PRESIDENT.
JOE BIDEN’S USE OF THAT WORD,
HONOR, WHICH IN ANY OTHER TIME I
THINK WOULD BE A THROWAWAY LINE
IN THE POLITICAL SPEECH, FOR ME
HAD SOME REAL RESONANCE.
>> Tucker: HONOR, THE ALL.
YOU COULD HEAR THE JOY IN HIS
VOICE.
THIS IS THE ATHEIST PARTY’S
VERSION OF CHRISTMAS.
BUT THEY ARE HAPPIEST ABOUT IS
THOUGH VOTING IS EFFECTIVELY
OVER, VOTING IS THE DEMOCRACY
PORTION OF THE PROCESS, THEIR
LEAST FAVORITE PART.
THAT IS OVER WITH.
ONTO THE CONVENTION!
ONTO THE NI DURATION AND BEST OF
ALL ONTO POWER.
THAT’S WHAT THEY ARE THINKING
RIGHT NOW.
THERE’S A PROBLEM.
THE ELECTION IS STILL 237 DAYS
AWAY.
IN THE CONTEXT OF A PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN, THAT’S AN AWFULLY LONG
TIME.
JOE BIDEN IS RIGHT NOW ABOUT AS
POPULAR AS HE’S EVER GOING TO
BE.
BOTH POLLING AND PRIMARY RESULTS
SO FAR SUGGEST THAT BIDEN DOES
BEST WITH VOTERS WHO DON’T
FOLLOW POLITICS VERY CLOSELY AND
HAVEN’T THOUGHT ABOUT THE RACE
VERY MUCH.
THEY KNOW BIDEN’S NAME.
THEY KNOW HE ONCE WORKED FOR
BARACK OBAMA.
THEY KNOW HE ISN’T THAT RADICAL
AND SCARY GUY FROM VERMONT SO
THE TRICK FOR THE DNC AT THIS
POINT IS TO MAKE CERTAIN THEY
NEVER LEARN MORE THAN THAT.
DEMOCRATS WOULD LOVE TO GO ALL
THE WAY TO NOVEMBER WITHOUT
ALLOWING BIDEN OUT OF THE HOUSE,
BUT THEY CAN’T DO THAT.
IT’S TOO OBVIOUS.
THEY WILL HAVE TO LET HIM
CAMPAIGN TO SOME LIMITED EXTENT.
EVERY TIME JOE BIDEN LEAVES THE
SUBURBAN, HIS ENTIRE TENNESSEE
HANGS IN THE BALANCE.
WILL HE BRAG ABOUT THE TIME HE
WENT TO BURNING MAN WITH
MARTIN LUTHER KING?
WILL HE MISTAKE HIS WIFE FOR THE
GOVERNOR OF OREGON QUESTION
WRIGLEY THREATENED TO PUNCH OUT
A COP?
YOU JUST DON’T KNOW.
WITH BIDEN, ANYTHING IS
POSSIBLE.
THE WHOLE THING MAKES THEM VERY,
VERY NERVOUS.
LAST NIGHT CONGRESSMAN JIM
CLYBURN OF SOUTH CAROLINA
SUGGESTED THE DNC OUGHT TO STEP
IN IMMEDIATELY AND CANCEL ANY
MORE DEBATES.
>> IF THE NIGHT AND THE WAY IT
HAS BEGUN, I THINK IT’S TIME FOR
US TO SET THIS PRIMARY DOWN.
IT’S TIME FOR US TO CANCEL THE
REST OF THESE DEBATES.
YOU DON’T DO ANYTHING TO GET
YOURSELF IN TROUBLE IF YOU
CONTINUE THIS CONTEST WHEN IT’S
OBVIOUS THAT THE NUMBERS WILL
ANNOUNCE IT FOR YOU.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE TO SHUT IT
DOWN.
LOCK HIM IN THE BASEMENT UNTIL
NOVEMBER.
CLYBURN DIDN’T SAY THAT LIGHTLY.
AT THE LAST DEMOCRATIC DEBATE
JOE BIDEN SPOKE FOR ONE SEVENTH
OF THE TOTAL TIME.
AT THE DEBATE THIS ON THE HE
WILL SPEAK FOR ROUGHLY HALF THE
TOTAL TIME.
IF YOU ARE JOE BIDEN, THAT’S A
LOT OF TIME.
IS A LOT OF CHANCES TO SCARE THE
HELL OUT OF PROSPECTIVE VOTERS.
IF YOU’RE THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN,
SPEAKING AT ALL IN PUBLIC IS
MOSTLY DOWN SIDE.
YOU CAN IMAGINE THE PRESSURE ON
BERNIE SANDERS TONIGHT TO DROP
OUT BEFORE ANY OF THAT CAN
HAPPEN.
AS OF NOW, SANDERS HAS NOT CAVED
AND ACTUALLY YOU CAN SEE WHY
HE’S NOT CAVING.
BIDEN IS VERY LIKELY TO WIN THE
NOMINATION BUT HE DOESN’T YET
HAVE IT.
IN FACT HE’S BARELY HALFWAY TO
THE MAJORITY OF DELEGATES.
SANDERS COULD STAY IN THE RACE
FOR A WHILE AND IT’S NOT
ENTIRELY CRAZY STRATEGY.
ATAT THIS POINT HONESTLY WHO KNO
WHAT COULD HAPPEN.
ANYONE WHO BELIEVES JOE BIDEN
WILL ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTION AT
ALL BE THE DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE IN
NOVEMBER, HASN’T BEEN WATCHING
AMERICAN POLITICS FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS.
THAT APPEARS TO BE BERNIE’S
POSITION.
>> DONALD TRUMP MUST BE
DEFEATED, AND I WILL DO
EVERYTHING IN MY POWER TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
ON SUNDAY NIGHT, IN THE FIRST
ONE-ON-ONE DEBATE OF THIS
CAMPAIGN, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
WHICH CANDIDATE IS BEST
POSITIONED TO ACCOMPLISH THAT
GOAL.
>> Tucker: THE LAST POINT IS A
FAIR POINT.
AMERICA HAS THE RIGHT TO SEE
JOE BIDEN ANSWER QUESTIONS ON
STAGE.
IF IT WERE UP TO THE STOOGES ON
CABLE TELEVISION, BIDEN WOULD BE
THE PRESENT ALREADY, NO ELECTION
BUT HOLD ON FOR SECOND, NOT SO
FAST.
BEFORE WE MAKE ANY RASH
DECISIONS THAT COULD ALTER THE
COURSE OF AMERICAN HISTORY
FOREVER, LET’S TAKE A LONG,
CLOSE LOOK AT THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATESCANDIDATE, THE PRISMS